peter brown with a gamespot news update
you know those great GTA mods you're
downloading on pc well a lot of users
found that one of them contains a bunch
of malware including a keylogger a post
today on GTA forms reveals that angry
planes and no clip mods could be
packaged with self installing malware
infected mods could potentially install
a trojan called fade exe which then
creates log files which are transmitted
online it is unknown what information is
transmitted but possibilities include
personal information and passwords if
you use those mods it would be wise to
exercise caution make sure your
antivirus software is up to date and
change your passwords on sensitive
websites this isn't the first time that
mods have distributed malware but it is
a reminder to be cautious when
installing them especially due to the
lack of official mod support by Rockstar
so listen if you're a keylogger out
there please don't tell my boss about my
cougar search history just a little
embarrassing anyway more gaming news
stay tuned to gamespot com